today on stick to football we are fixing
counters Jets because after monday night
football they desperately need it we're
also gonna look at the trade deadline
some traits we want to see happen some
trades we think might happen and of
course we're gonna answer your guy's
draft on draft questions but as always
make sure you're watching us on youtube
because i actually think i mean we both
look pretty damn good today so get on
Bleacher Report's youtube channel look
for the stick to football playlist and
Connor I don't know about you but I am
already excited because on Friday you
and I will be flying to London not
together unfortunately for our event on
Sunday at O'Neill's on Carnaby I add a
couple people DM Ian they're like hey
there are four O'Neill's in London which
one are you guys going to be at so I
hope I'm saying this right but we'll be
it at Carnaby Street for this event from
four o'clock until whenever and we've
been told daylight savings time
apparently works differently in London
so not definitely but because our
daylight is different right like we go a
week later than them I don't understand
daylight savings time anyway it's stupid
but the games there kickoff at 5:00 so
you can come hang out with us for an
hour and pregame while we record the
podcast and then the games kickoff at
5:00 and we can watch those together
yeah it's gonna be awesome and as we
always tell everyone we don't know when
we're leaving we're doing the show
before the games that's what matters let
go be with us there on Sunday as well so
we'll all be doing some stuff together
but listen if you're going to the game I
know we've heard some from our great
listeners over there that said they
won't be able to make it because they'll
be at the game who check on it check on
it after we might still be there who
knows and we're really excited for all
the people that did reach out that are
gonna make it to the game and a big
THANK YOU to them for that tip that the
clocks going back and then me and Matt
will get back in the States
and the clocks will go back here
whatever we'll figure it out this give
back we got home from Vegas and I didn't
know how to sleep or breathe days a week
okay well I'll eventually just lay down
and fall asleep and I'll wake up and it
will be a time we also employ can come
to this tailgate they're the one we're
about to talk about I encourage it
because I think this is gonna be the
best one that we've had in two years of
the tailgate tour no disrespect to
Madison Baton Rouge Austin we Columbus
Ohio we've been some amazing places but
no
ix in Tuscaloosa Alabama the game it
just got announced is at 2:30 kickoff so
we are probably gonna be there at about
7:00 a.m. set up we have a tent a 20 by
20 tent on the quad gonna be set up look
for us look for the stick to football
guys we are gonna have food we're gonna
have beverages we're gonna have a ton of
fun things to do all day it's free you
don't have to have a ticket to the game
just come tailgate with us
Adam Kramer is gonna be there I've heard
our guy Jacob Hester might stop by again
so it's gonna be a lot of fun we want
everyone to be there Tuscaloosa Alabama
November 9th 7 a.m. until kickoff
basically yeah it's gonna be basically
the national championship game of the
year during the regular season which is
incredible we can't wait for that whole
squads gonna be there plenty of sick the
football friends are gonna be there and
if you've never been to a tailgate like
Matt said the get over this is the one
to make it - we're gonna have a food at
this one drinks plenty of fun and we'll
be there the whole time so let's get
into it Matt a lot of news around the
league and we don't need to talk about
the embarrassment that was my New York
Jets
yeah sure because we're good we're gonna
fix them later so we can get into that
embarrassment later but let's start with
something that happened before the game
and that is shefter kind of hinting that
Tom Brady could be leaving New England
after the season I never buy into this
stuff but I did find it interesting not
only when you tweeted it but then when I
went back and watched the video again
how you know sure shefter almost so
here's what's amazing this got buried
like no I did anyone talk about this I
saw some like at crazy fan takes tweet
it so I watched the video and was like
oh [ __ ] this is a big deal so Adam
Schefter on Monday night countdown goes
on there and says listen Tom Brady has
sold his house he has his trainer has
sold his house
tom has restructured his contract to
where there's an out after this season
and he's basically setting it up like
Tom might not want to retire but he
might know his time is done in New
England in which then Steve young
doubles down and was like listen this
some Jerry Rice and I talked about I
wanted to retire a Niner Jerry wanted to
keep playing ball and at some point you
know you're at the end of your run with
that team and you start setting things
up to go elsewhere I
I've always been skeptical in the past
two people connecting dots like
so-and-so sold their house they're
definitely gonna retire or they're
definitely being moved with Brady I mean
he's such a calculated individual but I
stand by this and I've heard a lot of
rumors over my now nine years of doing
this job of bleacher report the the Tom
Brady rumors have always been crazy but
I will say that several years back when
there was maybe talk that Bill Belichick
preferred Jimmy Garoppolo over Tom Brady
Robert Kraft squashed that he
emphatically said no Tommy is our
quarterback as long as he wants to be
Kraft thinks of Brady like a son that
relationship is I mean it's very
paternal I would be shocked if Robert
Kraft let Tom Brady ever play anywhere
other than the New England Patriots I
would be too that's an main reason I'm
not buying into it is because they had a
successor that they drafted and
developed and that was playing well
there in a very short you know sample
size and Kraft came over the top and he
never did that to Belichick before but
he came over the top and they stuck it
out with Tom Brady obviously everything
worked out in the end there but I'm not
a buyer that they're sitting there and
going well we have Jared Stidham right
now we're really right and move on okay
yeah I don't think it's time for that
just yet so but it was interesting it
was very interesting to me to [ __ ]
he's not know and I think yeah one on
set and even Randy Moss was like okay
where does he play and shefter didn't
know how to even know what to say he was
like well I think there's a half a dozen
teams or a dozen teams that will want
Tom Brady in it thankfully whoever was
hosting knew to get out of it you know
but it was like okay like where where do
you see him going my one question and I
don't want people to get upset at this
conversation cuz we're just spitballing
here we're not saying Brady's leaving
the only reason I can think of that Tom
would want to leave at this point of his
career is just to prove anyone out there
and I know there's not many at this
point because it's so ridiculous but to
prove out there that he could have won
anywhere that it wasn't always just bill
that he could go I don't know to say to
a Chicago who knows but and go win up
one more title elsewhere and then it's
really undisputed that he's the greatest
of all time
you don't think he is already I don't
want to make this a Patriots show
although I probably need to talk about
the Patriots more than we actually do
well I think I'm at Sanu now so we're
gonna talk about that too look at Bill
Belichick's record before Tom Brady it
wasn't good so everybody was like
Brady's the system quarterback that's
always my argument it's like look at
Belichick before Brady who made who is
maybe it's a chicken or the egg but like
you said the Patriots traded for Mohamed
Sanu I woke up and the first thing I saw
my phone this morning was a text from
you and then it was the news about this
trade and I thought like wait a second
does I see a second rounder so I like
grab my glasses put them on it's like oh
that says a second round pick for 30
year-old Mohamed Sanu who has basically
a year and a half left on his deal it's
very a very inexpensive deal this is
good for the Patriots in terms of
contract but worried I was surprised
that a second round pick and it will
probably pick 64 so that that has to be
put in there as well but a second round
pick for Mohamed Sanu did surprise me it
surprised me too and I think even more
so was that they were saying they were
trying to get him during the draft and
Atlanta was not ready to move him
obviously Atlanta much like I personally
thought I thought they were gonna be
competitive this year they thought they
were gonna be competitive this year they
fully realized that's not happening and
now they were ready to pull the trigger
I don't care if this is pick what Matt
63 or 64 whatever it's gonna be in the
second round you got a second round pick
for Mohamed Sanu
and you already drafted Calvin Ridley
where you feel good about your receiver
core there now let's talk about the New
England fit cuz yes this is a great
return for Atlanta but for a New England
Sanu is a guy that'll fit seamlessly
into their system he will buy in as a
blocker I mean they love that especially
with this very run heavy attack and I
think he could do a lot of things after
the catch and everybody's been talking
about his passing numbers which is just
another fun thing to add to the phone
he's under contract for next year at
what for New England's cap is probably a
pretty reasonable rate so if Josh Gordon
has injury concerns or any kind of
long-term concerns they really did need
to add a receiver for the next two years
because and they kill Harry even if he
comes off IR it's gonna take a little
time to get back full right and with
Josh Gordon I think a lot of people
forget that he's finally gonna be a free
agent after this year
so the did forget oh no
he would move on but there's a
possibility that he would move on maybe
through his art they're not always big
about painting guys so he could
definitely move on Sanu also went to
Rutgers and if you know anything about
Bill Belichick you know how much he
loves Rutgers his son Steve was there at
the same time that Sanu was at Rutgers
the Mike Ortiz were there john harmon
was there there's a lot of a connection
between
sanu and this team and you're right
they've been trying to trade for this
guy
I'd heard even but I know I think
Rapoport like you said was saying during
the draft I'd heard even before the
draft they were trying to trade for this
guy so Bill Belichick loves Mohamed Sanu
and he was probably I mean obviously he
was willing to give up pick number 64 in
the draft and the Patriots just don't
value the draft like everyone else does
which you know they would rather have
veterans come in because it's win now
they just want a guy that can do a job
and they will they'll find that through
free agency your traits one more trade
now they got done this week in the
deadline is Tuesday so there's still
plenty of time for trades to happen I
expect a lot more will one big one that
shook things up a little bit on Monday
was that Gary and Conley a former first
rounder was traded to the Houston Texans
for a third-round pick the Texans now
basically don't have any draft picks in
the the 2020 NFL Draft
they have traded for Laremy Tunsil
they've traded for Kenny Stills they
they're just very depleted right now
when it comes to draft picks they have a
second and they have a fourth and then
they got a couple day three picks is
there it comes in and has nothing to
work with
yeah a second to fourth a fifth sixth
and a seventh so yeah not not a lot but
they do have Gary and Conley who you
know let's go back in time his career
started weird he was drafted there were
the allegations of sexual assault that
nothing ever came from that then there
was the injuries and it was like he had
chronic shin splints and really couldn't
get on the field early in his career it
seemed like he was starting to turn the
page last year this year the Raiders are
running a ton of zone coverage this is
not what he's a good fit for so
hopefully a change of scenery will be
good for him a change his scheme as well
but I really like Darren Conley coming
out of Ohio State and he was there when
they had some studs obviously Marshall
Moore was on the other side of him but I
like my cooker I liked Conley enough to
have a first round great on him and
hopefully he said hopefully this change
of scenery will be big for him
the Texans need corner help I know
they've liked what they've seen from
Lonnie Johnson but they they need some
help on the backend yeah they really did
they really needed help in the secondary
obviously a tough loss to the Colts this
past weekend and this is a flyer
I know third-round picks can be valuable
but Gary and Conley there was a time
where he was living up to that
first-round talent that he is now has it
worked out since another problem I have
too is I just don't think Jonna grew
never really wanted this guy to be
completely transparent with you here so
do I think the talent is there where he
can get back to that first round for him
I truly do and that's the kind of risk
you take with the third round pick out a
season where you're competitive
but you also getting a 24 year old
player that can help you for the long
term yeah I mean it's a smart business
if if it works in them not right now the
Raiders are loaded up with draft picks
and so they'll probably draft another
guy from Clemson
it's what mike Mayock will do let's take
a break we come back we're going to do
the Lord's work we're gonna fix the New
York Jets if you were forced to watch
Monday Night Football you know that we
needed to speak to the New York Jets oh
my god I I text somebody it's like I
actually have to watch this entire game
it's my job and so it's like you look
for things like Route four and I was
just rooting for the Patriots to
continue to score but the Jets need a
lot of work they really do we were gonna
fix the Dolphins today and like had it
all ready to go and last night was so
bad really cap
we should probably fix the Jets today
and I know everyone's gonna want to talk
about the coaching staff and what they
should do but let's let's do what you
have to first because the trade deadline
is Tuesday and I look at this team and
say I want to do something to Mike
mechag ninh should have done and never
really could get to and it's funny that
you know over the course of a couple
years the Jets drafted all these great
defensive tackles Leonard Williams
Mohammad Wilkerson Sheldon Richardson
you know none of them are gonna be on
the team next season so I date why did
the last regime fail you can look at
those picks and say okay well at the
time they looked like good picks but
don't worry teams last two were shapes
excuse me that last two regimes so I'm
going to finish the job and trade
Leonard Williams get some return on
investment for this guy while you can he
is said to be a free agent after this
year you're not bringing him back not
after you drafted our
Lord and Savior at number four overall
or number three overall Quintin Williams
so I would trade Leonard Williams get
what you can because I don't I think you
could get better than the third round
compensatory late third round
compensatory pick that you would that
you would get in return for him yeah I
think so too it's interesting I had
heard last offseason that the front
office before they were let go had at
least one offer of a second round pick
on the table for Leonard Williams and
that the new coaching staff which was in
place did not want to get rid of him
they felt like they they needed to go
into battle with all their guys they
hadn't taken Quinn and Williams yet they
didn't know how that board was gonna
fall which that's such poor preparation
you should have known Quintin Williams
probably be the pick at 3:00 exactly and
they didn't make the move and now the
question is can you still get that
second rounder for Leonard Williams no
you're a variety of opinions on this I
think I know there's people that are
like hey we'll add a three flyer pick
work it will not I know Leonard Williams
is taking a lot of heat but coaches
around the NFL really like Leonard
Williams
I think teams around the NFL the Cowboys
really need interior d-line help I don't
know how much they'll be willing to pay
that's the one that stands out that's
the one that stands out I think you
could see a scenario where Leonard
Williams brings you back a third-round
pick maybe a conditional third that can
become a second-round pick but at the
end of the day Matt I think you're right
I think you can get more than the
compensatory selection and if you're Joe
Douglas you have Henry Anderson on a
long term contract you know you have
Coyne and Williams there here's the
kicker
they just gave Steve McClendon a
one-year extension on that d-line who's
basically the captain and the team right
now there's no room for Leonard Williams
after this year and they're not gonna
pay him so I'm with you I think that's
step one in fixing the Jets is moving
him and getting a pick for next year I
wonder and I know it's not maybe the
biggest knee but where Seattle has
struggled so much to get a pass rush
right now and Ron Reed's just now
getting back and getting his younger
things but I wonder if you don't call
Seattle and say hey you guys are you're
a playoff team but you're gonna have to
bolster that pass rusher you're not
going anywhere I wonder if that's not a
phone call you make other than like you
said I mean there's Dallas is the
obvious one but I don't know how much
they'd be willing to pay but I think
Leonard Williams you got to go and I
felt this way about Sheldon I felt the
way about moe
you want to get rid of these guys while
they still have some value so again
you're probably gonna get you know
picking the 90s or early 100's if he
leaves as a compensatory pick but that
wouldn't be until 2021 so you're getting
a little bit of return on investment
faster so step two we get past Tuesday
past the trade deadline step two for me
and I know last night was rough but I
need to see what the Jets have in rookie
offensive linemen to madoka because
there have been times he's looked really
good and he's looked really quick go
back to the Dallas game like watching
Dallas film I thought this might be the
left tackle the future last night I
thought this guy might be a backup so we
need to figure out who he is this is a
lost season obviously so let's see who
he is over the course the year left
tackle you need audition him there
because if not you're looking at someone
like Andrew Thomas or Tristan wharfs or
Austin Jackson in the upcoming draft
class so I think it's very important in
the rest of this season to see what you
have out of a toga left tackle
here's my question for you Matt now
Calvin btrim be a free agent at the end
of this year and he's hurt he didn't
play last night and it didn't matter who
played last night because the Patriots
ran cover zero writes the [ __ ] out of
the Jets and there was nothing they
could do when it comes down to it do you
bring Beach him back and play him at
left tackle this year Ford Arnold's
development and a Doga on the right side
or do you just say hey Sam's got to
figure it out we need to see what a Doga
has on the left side right now I would
say you got to see what a toga has on
the left side but I also one of my
biggest complaints that I yelled at my
TV last night were that the Jets did not
adjust and have very many quit all quick
routes for Darnell it's like he said it
cover zero nothing they did nothing to
really slow down the Patriots
linebackers especially so I think that
goes on Adam GaSe and the offensive
staff to say ok we're gonna have a young
still-developing 22 year old quarterback
we're gonna have a rookie left tackle we
need to help them out a little bit and
and be able to adjust in game some so I
know that might be asking a lot from
Adam GaSe but I would say I want to see
what these two former USC guys do
together and that takes me right to my
third point big one I know that before
the season I said I like Adam GaSe of
the candidates the Jets interviewed I
liked Adam GaSe
once it looks like Matt Campbell wasn't
gonna go there I really thought that he
would be able to develop Sam's Arnold
but then this season just like took such
a weird turn for the Jets Arnold gets
sick
the offensive line gets you know injured
and doesn't look good and there's the
whole caliche assimilate thing going on
the defense has not been great I would
fire Adam GaSe and Greg Williams I think
an important thing for a front office an
important thing for owner is to say hey
that didn't work and it didn't work and
being able to admit that now is better
than waiting and losing more of Sam
Donald's rookie contract window to a
mistake I would fire Adam GaSe I would
fire Greg Williams and I would go to
guys like Matt rule I would probably go
back and say hey I know Mack Agnon
didn't want to let you pick your own
offensive coordinator and they tried to
force Todd mocking down your throat
we're sorry why don't you come try this
again because there was an obvious
connection there I would call Mattie
Campbell back and say okay you've seen
the ceiling at Iowa State man let's
let's try this somewhere else and if
you're not gonna bounce to a bigger
power five school and you're probably
not come to the NFL bring that CEO and
that culture building style that has him
one of the top head coaching candidates
bring that to the NFL and see what it
can do if neither of those guys are
ready to leave college I would be very
very interested to interview both of the
coordinators in San Francisco right now
but I I think they're doing a fantastic
job Mike McDaniels ability to scheme up
the run game I know a lot of that's Kyle
Shanahan but Mike McDaniels ability to
work under him and it's basically the
run game coordinator I have heard
nothing but good things about Mike
especially over the last couple years I
would be interested to interview him and
see what he's got there he's never been
interviewed for a head coaching job so
it's it's truly an unknown but I think
he's gonna be a very interesting name
and being able to pair him with levy on
Bell and Sam Donald I look at that San
Francisco offense it's like what they do
schematically would work so well with
Darnell Dan belt yeah and some of these
free agents and draft picks we're gonna
get into later would align perfectly
with what Mike McDaniel does best and
that scheme up the run and levy on is
gonna be here next year levy on looks
great on Monday night I just want to say
that for how bad the team played
literally an embarrassing effort levy on
looks great and I think they should feel
good about that signing if they want to
feel good about something moving us
thing here though because I want to
touch in your coaching points I
with the order you need to almost write
an apology to Matt rule and say hey
let's try this again right but I think
Joe Douglas actually brings a different
level of credibility when trying to
bring in a coaching hire now how Sam's
arnold performs the rest of the year is
also gonna matter
now they play Jacksonville they play
Miami twice they play Washington they
play Oakland they play teams that are
not going to look like the best defense
in the NFL that's the New England
Patriots and we saw what Sam did against
Dallas I know Sam wood had a horrific
night Monday he's a better player than
that I think he will rebound from all of
this and I think that's something that
might entice one of these coaches
whether it's Matt rule you know how much
I love Matt Campbell as well I think
McDaniel is the most intriguing of the
bunch now it does suck a little bit for
Gregg Williams because he's been way
better than I expected this year I think
the defense has done everything they can
they have no corners besides Brian Poole
and Greg is just doing everything you
can even New England last night there
were times where they didn't just run
down the field but the Jets our offense
put the defense in such a bad position
so many times that it was the inevitable
so it does start with this coaching list
now this coaching list is going to
expand as the season goes on you know
just to get away from some of these
college guys and coordinator guys Matt
is there anyone that you could see let
go as a retread that you think deserves
an interview whether it is a Mike Tomlin
I don't know if they move on from him
but throw his name into the pool Jay
Gruden one of these guys I would be
interested Jay Gruden because of the Sam
Donald and it seems like hires go
ping-pong so it's okay what defensive
guys because you're just hired an
offensive kind of didn't work yeah I
think Dan Quinn's a much better coach
than Atlanta it's playing right now I
think his I don't know if it just got
stale there or what Mike Collins name is
surfaced a lot is maybe he will be out
in Pittsburgh after this year that's
such a stable franchise I don't know if
they would be willing to move on but I
think also someone like Dave Tabb who's
the special teams coordinator in Kansas
City his name has been floated a lot in
recent years so not your obvious like
college head coach or offensive
coordinator but someone who you know is
he's not gonna bring like dynamic X's
and O's but it's more about what he
could do as a staff builder that I think
would be really exciting but as far as
the red tread guys go like you know I'm
not jumping up and down and yet Mike
McCarthy I
that yeah I don't want to go that route
I mean they interviewed him and I know
it was a different crew but the owner
was in on the interviews you know and I
heard that it just did not go well I
think Mike is it was pretty checked out
after a Green Bay maybe he needed a year
to take off and refresh I know there are
people that are singing now and saying
well I told you they should have hired
him that was not the answer at the time
and I don't think it's the answer in the
future
no two names that I would throw out
there something is funny because he was
mentioned before John Dee Philippe who's
done a really good job Jacksonville this
year with Gardner Minshew
and then I don't know if Gary Kubiak
would ever want to get back in what he's
done in Minnesota as the offensive
coordinator amazing it really deserves
more credit than it's been given so I
look at those two guys as names that
we've heard before Kubiak has a Super
Bowl ring but you know guys hoop man
those are those are pretty good coaches
that are under the radar right now the
Saints have a couple guys and Pete
Carmichael and Dan Campbell who should
be getting more love than they are so
there's there's some good coaches out
there that aren't in the the obvious
names we talked about let's transition a
free agency because that will be huge
for the Jets we've seen them try to be
big spenders last year they actually
were you get CJ Mosley you get levy on
bail they really went for broke then
that front office got fired so what do
they do this year I feel like it'll be
more conservative under Joe Douglas who
has not been as aggressive as Howie
Grossman the guy he kind of learned
under in Philadelphia so I think we're
gonna learn a lot about Joe and how he
wants to run his team a guy I would keep
though I would do everything I could to
keep Robbie Anderson I think he's much
better than some of the situation's he's
been put in we've seen flashes of what
he can do especially against Dallas with
Sam in there and then if you're gonna go
to market to try to improve this team I
would try to pay for one pass rusher in
one corner and then draft those
positions as well I like a Shaq Barrett
who's on a one-year deal right now in
Tampa Bay he's gonna be near the top of
the league sack leaders I mean he could
be a really good fit especially if
you're gonna run more of that type of
defense and again if we're firing the
coaching staff no more Greg Williams
thank God I think Shaq Barrett would be
fun and then I still like trae Waynes I
know he's kind of had an up-and-down
career in Minnesota but he's sighs his
ability to play man coverage I would and
that's not like you're not paying trae
Waynes a ton of
so he's someone I would be interested in
as a mid tier free agent at corner yeah
and when you look at this salary cap
situation you're right Matt they spent a
lot of money last offseason and they're
still going in with more than 50 million
in 2020 and that's without a lot of
obvious cuts they could save a little
bit of the tremaine johnson contract
although that was a nightmare 11.5
million for Caleta Semele can be saved
six million from Darryl Roberts another
7.5 million from Bryan winter so if Joe
Douglas wants to blow this thing up and
go in and have a 80 million dollar
spending spree he could do it and that's
when it starts with me you made a great
point bring back Robbie Anderson he's
your deep threat I think he'll flourish
when the offensive line actually gives
the quarterback some time to throw the
football down the field and I would
bring back Brian Poole they signed him
on a one-year deal he's been a great
corner for the slot they have no one on
the outside but he's done a really nice
job on the inside I'd bring back Brian
Poole that has to be a priority on the
internal free agency when you look at
you did a great job on the defensive end
go get a pass rusher like Shaq Barrett
helped at corner another corner I'll
throw into the mix he'll be to ease 27
right now I'll turn 28 next season
I wonder what Byron Jones is going to
command on the free agent market I heard
a lot yeah could be a lot of money and
if it is I would probably stay away
because some of the injuries some of the
inconsistent play you love his flashes
but that's a name that's gonna be very
interesting for me as the Jets look to
assess corner into your offensive line
needs to be rebuilt I know the tackles
we'll get to that in the mock draft a
little bit but right now I look at
Brandon Scherff is set to hit free
agency you need a dominant powerhouse
guard that can get things going for levy
on bail you need a new center the Ryan
Khalil experiment has been a disaster
either JC Treader from the Browns Trey
Hopkins from the Bengals we talked about
both those guys when we fixed the
Bengals if one of them makes it's a free
agency Joe Douglas has to realize this
anterior offensive line needs to be
rebuilt right away to give their
quarterback a chance and now it's time
let's have some fun and do some mock
drafting I like that you want the
buffalo style here like we're paying an
offensive line guys why buy an offensive
that wrapped some we're not done yet
right it's working for Buffalo so here's
what I want to preface this by saying
the jet schedule they can realistically
win four or five more games because they
have the dolphin
in their place it seems there's a place
[ __ ] teams they play the Redskins they
play the Steelers they could win four or
five more games so they could be
drafting anywhere from I mean five to
twelve and it wouldn't surprise me
basically because they could win enough
games right now they're slotted to be at
five at one and five but I mean this
could be a five and 11 type team which
is gonna push you down the board so keep
that in mind I don't have chase young
falling in this one if they are at five
my target would be Gerry Judi get Sam's
Arnold a true number one receiver no
disrespect to the solid receiver core
the Jets have they don't have a number
one I want Gerry Judy now if they end up
picking like eight nine ten I think your
focus becomes Andrew Thomas or Tristan
Dwarfs Thomas plays left tackle for
Georgia wharfs plays right tackle at
Iowa but a lot of people think he could
switch sides in the NFL those would be
my targets if you fall out of that top
tier of premium picks which I think Judy
will be in yeah I would love to get
Jerry Judy I don't know if he makes it
to them so I went with the the other
route and that is Andrew Thomas because
I think he could play a left tackle I
think you play a right tackle I think he
could play guard I really don't think it
doesn't matter he could play anywhere
he's a great run blocker he really is
I think he'd bring the right attitude to
this Jets offensive line and if you go
back to the free agency plan of getting
a center like JC Treader getting a guard
like Brandon Sheriff and you bring in
Andrew Thomas you're gonna see what you
have in shuma at Doga that's a start to
rebuilding this offensive line yeah it
absolutely is and that's that has to be
the key for them right now it's
rebuilding the offensive line in round
two now in an area that has been just
sorely overlooked by this team basically
since Darryl Ramos left and that is the
cornerback position I really like TCU's
Jeff Gladney in the second round he said
I believe ranked number 46 on my board
right now he has size he has very very
good coverage instincts and he's not on
a great defense this isn't a dude who's
out there with like stud safeties over
the top he is on an island almost weekly
so gladdening he's six foot about 190
pounds I compared him to Kyle fuller
when watching a couple games I think he
profiles as a starting corner in the NFL
and not it not a Seabee one he's not a
shut down
I'm not gonna lie to you but a very good
starter nonetheless I'm with you all the
way here for the Jeff Gladney pick I
think he is a plug in play corner that
should be available at the top of round
2 and that is very very important when
you talk about value here so Jeff
Gladney listen I don't know if they can
get out of the term a and Johnson
contract next year they're gonna take on
a lot of dead money they do have to
bring back Bryan pool but it's a start
at the cornerback position to get a guy
that's feisty physical and scrappy like
Gladney is yep round three I'm going
back to that edge position there are a
lot of guys that I really like in this
edge class as a values around three I
want to look at what the New England
Patriots did last year they got chase
one of hitch in the third round and he's
been a vision for them Kenny Willa kiss
at Michigan State is like a light
version of chase one image I don't know
that he plays with the quite the same
like motor and just insanity but he is a
hard-ass pass rusher man just his get up
field ability is great he's strong so I
like Kenny Willa cuz he might be a
situational pass rusher early in his
career but I think there's some
development potential there so I want
him at coming off the right side of that
defense as a rookie on third downs and
then hopefully he can develop into more
of a true three down player yeah I feel
like he's gonna get some of this chase
win of each comps this year going into
the draft and I think the Jets probably
regret passing on a guy like win a [ __ ]
and I went with the edges well here when
Anthony Jennings from Alabama now I
think he rises a little bit because
Alabama defenders always seem to have a
late surge when they aren't the guy that
defense it's like we went into the
summer and we're like alright dill Moses
gonna be at the top of every mock draft
then you get through more and more
taping you what about this guy what
about this guy and I think with Jennings
on the edge just an all-around very
solid defender and the Jets are once
again gonna have to add to that group
whether it is in free agency with Shaq
Barrett or a lesser name or in the draft
on day two and around 4:00 we both went
back to the middle of the offensive line
here stacking it have to just throw
picks at this especially in the middle
of the draft you can find starters a
garden center in the middle of the draft
Tommy Cramer from Notre Dame I know he
maybe hasn't ever lived up to his
recruiting height but he is a very solid
player he's smart he's technically sound
you know you're gonna get that from
Notre Dame guys and I like his tough
in the rhone run game he's six five he's
three thirteen I need he can work in a
zone blocking scheme whether that's
inside or outside zone so if we're
bringing in the guys from San Francisco
you need someone like Kramer in the run
game I think you'd be a perfect fit yeah
I'm with you there you need a couple bad
asses on this offensive line I think
Brian winters has regressed quite a bit
this year and once again I don't know if
they'll keep him out his salary next
year even if they do just keep stacking
chips with this group this interior
needs a makeover I think there's
potential to solve the tackle situation
at the top of the draft like I said with
Andrew Thomas but if you get Kramer you
start to have an identity and a little
bit of a tougher group in the trenches
here to block for levy on bail the trade
deadline is just a couple days away as
you're listening to this and we wanted
to take a look at it even though there
will probably be a trade while we're
recording or editing so something will
change this up no doubt because it
already happened Mohammed snoo going to
the Patriots so let's start with some
that here's one that I I don't know if
it'll happen but I want it - I want Vic
Beasley to be traded to the Baltimore
Ravens this team needs more juice at the
edge Russia position they're running
away with the AFC North this is a type
of situational move they could bolster
them Beasley has just been on a downhill
slide lately after you know pretty good
start to his career so a news new scene
could be good for him he's also a free
agent after this year so it's not it's
not gonna be an expensive trade but the
the Falcons are selling off pieces we've
seen that with Mohamed Sanu
being traded I think Vic Beasley he's
obviously on the trade block they might
have to lower their asking price to a
fourth or fifth round pick to which the
Ravens I think the Ravens would be
willing to do something like that to try
to help this pass rush as they get into
the playoff stretch
I want a 30 for 30 on his 15 and a half
sacks season yeah I mean it's crazy to
think at 23 24 years old he had a 15 and
a half sacks season now I noticed the
scheme helped them I understand all that
but he has fallen off an absolute cliff
out there and I'm with you Matt I don't
think the return on him is much now on
the fifth-year option the cap hit is so
high that a team will have to absorb
some money that that might be holding
this one back as well but I look at
Baltimore it's like everything they
touch turns to gold so let's
let's get him there give him a shot
exactly yeah second one for me maybe a
little bit of a Homer pick but I know
Emmanuel Sanders name has been floated
out there the Patriots had called about
him Emmanuel Sanders to the 49ers it has
not been talked enough how much the
49ers are getting by with bad receiver
play right now debo Samuel has done
really nothing and he has been banged up
Donte Pettis really hasn't done anything
they're surviving without a true number
one George Kittel is their number one I
think that the Kyle Shanahan and John
Lynch will realize we can run the ball
on almost anyone but eventually we're
gonna be able to throw to win and you're
gonna need playmakers to do that Sanders
is coming up toward the end of his deal
as well he's a good fit for them to get
really over the hump a Denver's probably
not gonna be asking much for an older
player like this another team that's
gonna be selling off parts I know Connor
you want to talk about one of those as
well but Emmanuel Sanders to the Niners
makes too much sense for me yeah I think
that's a great fit I am a little little
disappointed with the lack of production
early on from debo and I think Sanders
is someone like Kyle remember how much
Kyle valued Pierre Garcon I could see
the same way being a veteran would
Emmanuel Sanders and I've been going
across well I'm staying in the NFC here
with the Eagles that desperately needs
secondary help now I know we talked
about on the Monday show that it feels
like this has become a bit of a lost
season for Philadelphia now this is a
team that sure they can catch fire but
if this secondary doesn't get any better
things are not going to change and I
look at Chris Harris jr. the Broncos got
to be in fire-sale mode almost at this
point and I think Chris Harris is not
going to be back after this season if
you're Philadelphia this is the kind of
player you'd like to acquire on the
cheap he still plays at a high level
maybe use you bring them in and you
attack a band-aid deal on with them you
sign them be an extra year or two
extension and keep him in this
Philadelphia secondary so I don't think
the cost would be very high Matt I think
you'd be looking at probably a
third-round pick for someone like Chris
Harris and that can inject some life
into this Philadelphia secondary yeah I
love that move a lot of people have been
asking me about corners for the Kansas
City Chiefs are they gonna make a move
what kind of move will they make well we
know now that Jacksonville wouldn't even
consider trading Jalen Ramsey to the
Chiefs there's been talk about Patrick
Peterson but the Cardinals really seem
like they don't want to move him so what
will the Chiefs do here's my pretty
action absolutely nothing they only have
five pics their star quarterback is
gonna be out at least a week with that
knee dislocation I really look at the
Chiefs and I think that Brett Veatch
believes that once they get Eric Fisher
back once they get Sammy Watkins back
once this team is healthy Chris Jones
needs to come back kendall fuller us out
once they get healthy I honestly think
they believe they're good enough to win
a Super Bowl as is so with only five
picks in the 2020 Draft no really
expiring contracts that you're gonna
want to move for Kansas City I mean I
don't think they're trading Chris Jones
or Kendall fuller they're both free
agents and otherwise it's Darrin Lee
Reggie Ragland and Moe Claiborne those
guys aren't players that you would trade
all know so I think the Chiefs actually
stand pat this year yeah I think it's
about time they do listen they shift off
a lot of picks in recent years so it
makes sense and I thought we saw a
different I knows Denver but we saw a
different energy from this defense on
Thursday night and I believe even the
coaching staff you know gave a shout out
to somebody like Derek Nadi that they
feel is really turning the corner for
them so if you're looking at the Chiefs
right now I think you're actually okay
with not making a move here for once yep
and the last one the team that just big
move Mohamed Sanu goes to the Pats for a
second why not make one more trade
Oh Jay Howard to the Patriots is the
trade that we all need to happen he's
being just completely wasted in Tampa
Bay where they don't throw to the tight
end when they do it's camera break get
OJ out of Tampa send him to the Patriots
even if it's picked 32 in the draft that
they end up shipping him take it
I loved OJ Howard coming Alabama he's so
perfect for New England so perfect and
they're not gonna use him I think in
Tampa we're gonna see a decent amount of
turnover if they don't get things turned
around there whether Jays Jason like to
get an extension but I think Jameis is
probably gone we're gonna see this get
reworked so the Patriots they don't have
a lot of picks they have a first they
have a third they have a four two
fourths by the way find a way to make it
work even it yet even if you have the
trade at 2021 second-round pick get oh J
Howard to New England I know this has
probably been the season from Hell for
OJ Howard right now but I just think he
does not have a role in Bruce Arians
offense and I think he'd go to New
England and probably become a star he
always has the talent he's 24
years old he could do everything on the
field he really just needs the right
landing spot and yeah a lot of people
will scoff at that and say hey that's an
overpay but for some teams it's not and
I think New England is that team I do
want to say real quickly we didn't
mention guys like Trent Williams it does
not seem like why I don't want to move
them right they don't want to move them
this season which is so weird to me I
think they're just completely miss
playing the situation Kenya Drake's name
has been out there I don't know if
there's anyone who would really want
Canyon Drake the teams that are a
playoff team that needs our running back
there just aren't very many of those so
I know those two names are like hot hot
ones on the trade wire I just don't see
anyone stepping up to take them right
now no I'm with you all the way I think
I know we always throw a lot of names
into the Hat here but you got to look at
veterans on expiring contracts that team
simply are not going to bring back and
they know they need to get that value
right now it is draft on draft time
we've got a really handful of good ones
here let's start with Patrick
Chamberlain although it's still early
what is currently your most
controversial opinion about the 2020
draft I put this in here and I was gonna
save her for Friday because I wanted to
get Melo in but I put it in because I
felt like two weeks ago my job ro loved
was highly controversial and I don't
know if it still is because I say all
the time like I don't consume a lot of I
don't consume a lot of sports content I
try to consume almost no draft content
because you don't want anyone clouding
your opinion but I feel like I'm still
incredibly high on Boro who's my number
five overall player but I also might be
wrong about that so you guys let me know
if that's still a controversial take
yeah I don't think it is any more but
I'll counter with the controversial take
I think people are really gonna come
back to an opera about Perot but other
guys I think people are really gonna
come back to earth here on this
quarterback class I don't think it's
this special group that six guys belong
in the first round now well teams over
draft quarterbacks every year of course
Jacob Eason is probably gonna go in the
first round Jordan Love probably gonna
go in the first round
Justin Herbert probably going to go in
the first round Jalen Hertz has a chance
to just keep climbing because he's
gotten so much better under Lincoln
Riley but at the end of the day do I
think this is a group where we have six
future bonafide starters in this class I
personally don't see it
yeah no I agree with that I think we not
we specifically I think people overrated
this year's quarterback class and and
and the running back class I think it's
a good running my class but it's
necessary
generationally legendary yeah receivers
I'm all in a class very very good
receiver class is amazing all right our
guy Danny Kieffer again Congrats on the
nuptials to you and Kyla you're the GM
of the Bears do you go after a
quarterback right now in hopes of saving
the season do you wait until the
offseason to sign a free agent or
package your limited picks to move up in
the draft so the good news for the Bears
I actually wrote about this today if you
open your BR app you could see I did an
article and like the 10 best team fits
of two players or team fits with players
the Bears have two second-round picks
and I know that you probably don't want
to say okay well we trade it up to get
mr. Biscay that didn't work it so
clearly didn't work right now the Bears
would pick a 49 and 50 and when you talk
about okay can they sign someone they
could but I don't that's not the best
move right to go sign a player to say
okay we are going to sign Cam Newton or
we're gonna sign Nick Foles if he ends
up there estimated next year I believe
to be at about 18 million dollars under
the cap depending on how that that
fluctuates so I don't know that signing
someone's the option I actually and I
wrote this you can you can go look and
see
I think Jalen Hertz is the guy for them
and I don't necessarily love Jalen Hertz
as a passer but I think you can look at
Lamar Jackson look at Josh Allen you can
look at early Cam Newton guys who were
able to beat you with their legs and
their arm Jalen Hertz leads Oklahoma and
rushing and something that Matt naggy
said Sunday night has really stuck with
me they need leadership there they need
a fiery leader and that's what Jalen
Hurd says he asked this chip on his
shoulder he is a fantastic character guy
his leader grades and character grades
gonna be off the charts good when we get
to Draft 400 season so in terms of
second-round quarterbacks Jalen Hertz
would be my guy that way you're not
trying to package picks yeah I makes a
lot of sense I think when you look at it
nag ease probably sitting there saying
hey I believe this is someone that could
fit into my system and give us a lot of
different looks whether it's how you
how great his mobility is whether it's
how he's progressed as a thrower so I
don't think it's crazy at all I actually
really like that strategy and I think
you highlighted the most important thing
Matt this isn't a team with a salary cap
where I don't know how realistic and
watch it'll probably come out in the
next 24 hours or something I don't think
it's very realistic to trade for a guy
like Nick Foles and take on that kind of
money I think that's just too much as
much as they'd probably love to do that
I know a lot of people have brought up
Josh Rosen I don't see the Bears rolling
the dice like that I think that's just
as risky as mr. Biscay has been when it
comes down to it so listen I like your
strategy I think they look in the draft
and and try to really develop a guy that
can come in and play and you know maybe
take some speed bumps along the way but
at the end of the day can give you some
production in not to make this a bear
segment that offensive lines not good
and there's a terrible idea so I want
someone who can move around and make
plays that's why we're Hertz over
someone like Jacob Eason who I like even
better right now as a pro quarter right
prospect but that ability to beat you
with the legs is super important for me
with that o-line Nick Baker as the
Patriots just traded for Mohamed Sanu do
you feel teams are afraid to trade with
the Patriots as they rarely miss on a
player they trade for and find a role
for that player like during the draft
eval process I think that's a myth I
don't think I was good I did an exercise
the other day I was just bullshitting
with somebody you know that loves the
draft and I said look at New England's
last five drafts there's so many misses
in there which makes it more impressive
how they get by whether it's you DFAS
whether it's developing players that
didn't work out in one situation which I
know Nick is asking that kind of
question there I think there's also
plenty of trades that simply haven't
worked out for them a time so I don't
think teams are afraid to trade with New
England now it probably does make you
bat an eye like Atlanta held out for a
long time before trading them sue but
souza veteran player we know what
Mohamed Sanu is at 30 years old so I
actually don't buy into this rumor or
thought I really just don't think the
Belichick likes draft picks and there's
a lot to that I wrote about this once
that good teams like the Patriots number
one they don't have army roster spots to
fill with draft picks number two like
their players are probably better than a
draft pick and so if you evaluate the
draft horizontally you know like a
Seattle model and say okay our
quarterback is Tom Brady obviously no
quarterback in the draft is going to be
better than
so okay what about our backup
quarterback okay well we feel like Jarek
stidham's better than Brian Hoyer so we
value him you look at your left tackle
okay that's where I say a win we feel
like we're gonna lose Nate's older Isiah
when it's a starter level tackle you
know you evaluate the draft against your
current roster if the Patriots do that
the draft doesn't hold much value except
for like developmental type players you
know like a Jarrett's did them like it
chase win of it true they are getting
some production from JaJuan Williams you
know a second-round pick who everyone
thought is more of a developmental type
guy so I don't I think the Patriots are
they're such an enigma like you can't
look at the Patriots and learn a lot of
lessons about the NFL because now
they're not where they are an outlier
because of belcheck and Brady so I don't
I if I were ever to be a GM or if you
were to be Jim we couldn't look at the
Patriots say okay we're gonna do it that
way well they are not because you'll
have Tom Brady so good luck because and
you also have Belichick and you don't
have Josh McDaniels and you don't have
Ernie Adams you don't have these guys
who just work so well and tandem to
figure out the perfect fit for each each
player and like Nick says no one is
better in the NFL it's saying okay we
need this we need a slot corner okay
well let's go get Jonathan Jones who
would be you know what would he be for
most teams probably nothing or let's get
James White like those guys aren't
playing for anyone else but in New
England they are top of the line players
it's crazy how they do it here after
year but I really do like your point
that they are not a model to follow they
are something that they're just rare
it's rare it really is all right this
one from hashtag Glaser's out what
realistic head coach option do the
Giants have if they decide to fire
Shermer I let you answer this Matt but I
just want to start with it and I know
you've alluded to it on previous shows I
don't think Giants fans should be
talking about Lincoln Reilly right now
no I don't either I'm I know I joked
around on Twitter on Monday somebody's
like how would you fix the Giants I was
like wad I'd fire Dave gentleman hire
myself I'm Hanuman and then give him a
billion dollars basically um so I look
at the Giants and we mentioned some of
these names earlier I think you can look
at you know guys like a Gary Kubiak you
can look at something like John Dee
Phillippe some of these offensive
coordinators are doing really well in
the NFL right now I also I mean I think
Matt rule has to be an Emmy you consider
there he coached there
so I think that rules perfect for them
and they're big on that they're big on
like it's almost like Michigan or the
Yankees we're like they want people
who've been there but I feel like the
ownership with the Giants right now
needs to figure out who they are you
know a little bit because they they just
keep trying to go back to the well
moving on from Eli was a big first step
I have a lot of respect for Dave
cattleman he's been in the league a
really long time but guys who reach that
level you know the pinnacle the top of
the mountain he's won a Super Bowl ring
I think you have to give them a lot of
credit but I also think they need an
infusion of younger ideas you know of
let's get outside the box a little bit
when into a player evaluation and
positional valuing so I would say
someone like a younger head coach would
be my preference over someone like a
Gary Kubiak you know look at Matt rule
look at John Dee Phillipe look at the
guys in New Orleans that we mentioned
you know a Pete Carmichael would be such
a good fit for Daniel Jones
so I think you have to say okay what
kind of offense do we want who's gonna
work with Daniel Jones to go get someone
who would be a fit for that yeah which
is gonna be very interesting because I
don't I don't want to get into a Daniel
jones hate fest but I don't know if
daniel Jones sells a job right now
that's my question I don't know right if
he sells a job it goes to like what did
you think of him pre-draft do you want
to get with him because it's been a
rollercoaster the debut against Tampa
was great and since then it has not been
great and that happens at all young
quarterbacks we've seen it with Sam's
Arnold the highest of highs against
Dallas the lows lows against New England
that job might be open we've seen it I
mean across the board here obviously we
haven't seen many highs with Josh Rosen
but a lot of young quarterbacks Josh
Allen he's got some horrible games he's
had some good games so it really comes
down to what those coaching candidates
think of the quarterback all right this
one from drew rush how many years does
Andrew Luck retiring set the cult's back
he's just basically it's a long-winded
quite long rushing yeah but he basically
felt that you know they've drafted well
they were set to have a really bright
future with him I'll keep this one kind
of short and sweet on Monday we went in
depth about how the Colts are very for
real which ecobee percent and that the
front office has done a brilliant job
with this team
to set them up for short-term success
rebounding from the luck retirement and
keeping flexibility with presets
contract for long-term options so I
think if you're a Colts fan if you
didn't get to listen to that segment we
did spend a lot of time on them but also
that you should feel really good about
things going forward with or without I
don't think you set them back honestly
does seem that way it's a team that
already has the most caps pace they're
gonna have even more they are in great
shape and I think Jacoby percent's
playing well the thing is like you have
to separate like reality from where we
potential and Andrew Luck a hurt Andrew
Luck I don't know if he's better than
Jacobi percent right now
I made sure last year when he was
healthy there were times he looks like
an MVP candidate but he was hurt again
and so it's kind of like our Cam Newton
conversation yes when Cam Newton is
healthy he's really really good but when
he's not healthy you have a liability on
your hands and I think that's what we
were getting to that point a little bit
with luck so I like Jacoby Brissette and
now you have an inexpensive quarterback
to build your team around so I think
they're in fine shape last question from
Garrett Greenlee is Percy Harvin a good
comparison for KJ hammer the Penn State
redshirt sophomore who's just absolutely
amazing I I say he's Marquis Brown I
mean Percy Harvin maybe was some of the
run catch stuff but if I remember right
Percy wasn't a small dick yeah
Percy was definitely a lot taller like
three or four inches taller 511 184 is
what he was listed at yeah and KJ is not
as listed wait I'm sorry no he's like
165 170 yeah 500 is Harvin when he was
drafted so play cops not nuts yeah
different body type but I like it when
people turn out cops it makes you think
- makes you sit in the wheels a little
bit I've already locked in Marquis Brown
as my KJ handler so it doesn't feel good
when you just punch it into the dock I
know like I'm done I'm not changing this
company I'm not moving off this comp
cops are I guess the Martian April
they're a headache what an agent text me
last night he was like asking about
Kayla van chase on and so yeah I love
him you know he's great leader he's
finally healthy it's really starting to
come on he was like who's your comp and
I was like I don't know I guess it's
October and up cops for me just come if
I'm watching
player in it and it clicks it's like oh
god this is like watching like I
compared jobber to Jimmy Garoppolo and
it was like the third time I watched him
play and was like [ __ ] this is like
watching Garoppolo play so we chase on
and other guys like I Isaiah Simmons I
just have a huge question mark in his
comp box so much I mean a lot of players
like him
I don't know kam chancellor meets Myles
Jack like I don't know who his
comparison is yet so we'll get there I
have a couple comparisons locked in and
I feel really good about him but we'll
see it's a process also I know he hasn't
been a you know an incredible NFL player
it's hard to believe he's still 25 but
he's a great college player what about
Shaq Thompson remember him oh yeah I
loved him yeah me too and he's been a he
hasn't been a bad NFL player I want to
be clear he just never became that
superstar we thought he could be billed
as yeah he was like miles before miles
cuz he played running back he played
linebacker safety all these hybrids man
they are tough too tough to get a comp
down for it makes it very tough yeah I
might just say there isn't one
I don't know da redditors are never
gonna let that happen let's just call it
that all right that is our show right we
will be back Friday morning all three of
the gang and then next week Connor and I
will be in London you'll get a show on
Monday you'll get a show on Wednesday as
always so thanks for listening don't
forget subscribe on Apple podcast or
Spotify or wherever you get your shows
and watch us on Bleacher Report's
youtube channel